endings in the soul born franchise are
generally pretty vague and Dark Souls 3
is no exception so in this video I'm
going to do my best to explain each of
the four endings of Dark Souls 3 and
what they mean lore wise to the Dark
Souls universe let's start with the most
obvious linking the fire throughout the
game almost every NPC that aids you
pushes you towards this ending from the
fire keeper to andre the blacksmith the
players inform that their goal is to
link the fire and continue the current
age now the ending in game is actually
pretty simple after defeating the soul
of cinder the unconverted bonfire and
lets the flame consume their body
sitting down and assuming their role as
lord of cinder just as others have done
before them yet something is a bit off
when Gwyn first linked the flame it
erupted into a fiery explosion burning
many of his night stash in Dark Souls 1
if the chosen undead chooses to link the
flame it explodes covering the entire
kiln on fire these are both in stark
contrast with the meagre flame of Dark
Souls 3 which is barely able to engulf
just the unkennel let alone the entire
kiln from this we can infer that the
flame is weaker than it once was years
and years have been artificially
prolonged have taken their toll in the
first flame which was originally
supposed to fade during Gwynn's age this
is further evidence by the state of law
third the fire is still burning during
the game but lothric is a hodgepodge of
different lands from different times
being squeezed together the first flame
is no longer a grand age sustaining
power who knows if it will even be able
to survive another linking this first
ending to Dark Souls 3 seems to slightly
prolong the inevitable but not really
make much impact eventually the first
flame won't be able to even consume the
one linking it and it will fade the next
ending is considered the quote-unquote
true ending by the guidebook meaning
this is probably the closest thing to a
confirmed canonical ending we're going
to get this is the end of fire to
achieve this ending you have to give the
fire keeper the eyes of a fire keeper
found in the untended grapes the fire
keeper is framed by the frightful images
of betrayal
a world without fire but she serves you
and will follow your path once you
defeat the soul of cinder her summoning
sign will appear near the fire summon
her and she will initiate the end of
fire she takes the fire in her hand
lets it fade saying that darkness will
short please settle and indeed the
screen starts to really darken the world
seemingly entering is the age of dark
perhaps the first one ever yet the fire
keeper continues saying but one day tiny
flames will dance across the darkness
like embers linked by Lord's path ashen
one here is thou my voice still I think
there are two very important parts to
this firstly the flame will return the
fire keeper can see the eventual return
of the flames to the world meaning that
the cycles are still churning although
the age of dark now descends upon the
world a new age of fire will one day
break through the blackness just as the
first flame broke into the gray long ago
and created disparity the second piece
of importance is the fire Kiedis
question ashen one here is Thal my voice
still this seems to hint at the fire
keeper and the ashen one still have a
path to walk in this new Dark Age she
wants to see if the one she serves is
still with her so even though the fire
has faded the world will keep spinning
so to say the ashen one in the fire
keeper have some sort of future to live
perhaps so to do the others of the world
of Dark Souls 3 this ending embarks on a
path yet untrodden in the series I see
it as a pretty fitting way to close off
the franchise the third and final
official ending is the usurpation of
fire this is by far the most complicated
ending in terms of how to achieve it and
probably lower implications as well this
ending requires you to first have Yolo
the pilgrim draw power out of you in the
form of dark sigils making you an undead
next progress the quest line of honoré
allowing the pilgrim and the church to
abductor perform a right of wedlock with
Andre by impaling her head with the
sword of a vowel lastly to feed the soul
cinder and Link the first flame the
flame begins to consume you just as it
did in the actual linking ending but
with an ominous tone you begin to arrive
and wrestle with the flame eventually
collapsing when you awake the flame and
sword orbit ash the sun's edge has
turned white and Knights of the sable
church bow to you Lord of hollows even
honoré is among the ranks of hollows
honoring you this ending seems to be a
possible end or at least a corruption of
the cycles when you take the fire in you
wrestle for control of it instead of
feeding it with the souls you have
acquired and powering it you use it to
power you and your body yet the light
does not fade as it did in the end of
fire ending
there is an eventual fade to black but
it's nothing of the sort of loss of
light that occurs in the other ending as
yuria of launder requested you wrestled
the flame from its mantle the flame does
not appear to have gone out during this
I believe that when the undead took the
flame in it remained at least partially
intact and that is how the undead Lord
Apollo's utilizes it to strengthen
himself the flame keeps burning so the
Lord Apollo's can make use of its powers
regeneration and teleportation in a way
I guess the age of fire will continue in
a sense the fire is after all still
burning however this age of fire
definitely plays by different rules in
the previous this time almost all power
is consolidated in the lord of hollows
and subsequently lawn door his new realm
one thing to make note of is that lawn
door is being controlled by the
primordial serpent cop this note does
make this ending a little bit more
sinister and perhaps something that you
don't want to do one thing I still need
to mention is the last line of dialogue
in descending presumably lawn door lawn
Dorian hollow uttering
so for some reason land or the land of
Yolo urea and the primordial serpent
cough is not whole and it seems that
going down the Easter patient of fire
ending is the first step towards piecing
this land back together back in Dark
Souls 1 cough wanted to bring about an
age of dark but he sense appears to have
realized a dark age and a Dark Lord is
not the true path to the undead sentence
of the furtive pygmy or the his version
of the true path now he wishes for the
usurpation the Lord of Hallows to rise
and rest the flame for himself assuring
in a new kind of age an age of man or at
least as what cough wants us to think
there is one more ending but it is more
of a secret this ending brings no
achievement with it and would be pretty
hard to think of on your own I'm going
to call this the alternate end of fire
ending or just alternate as it branches
off from the end of fire towards the
last few seconds of the ending to
achieve this you must strike the fire
keeper as she hold the fading flame in
her hands during the end of fire doing
this prompts a new cutscene with the
ashen one taking the flame from the fire
keeper and holding it love to the Sun
part of the opening narration plays in
the background
nameless accursed undead unfit even to
be cinder
and so it is
the - seeketh embers
this is a pretty dark ending the
unnecessary cruelty shown to the
Firekeeper and the narrator's ominous
dialogue create a brooding almost
sinister atmosphere the narrator's words
help us piece together what happened
ashe seeketh amber the ashen one took
the flame for himself he sought ember
and the first flames probably be the
most powerful ember in the game so even
though this ending does branch off from
the end of fire I think it has a lot
more in common with the usurpation
ending as both include the player taking
the fire for himself and using its power
for some form of personal gain other
aspects that are important to take note
of in this ending are the amount of
light during the ending and II
perspective focus the fade to black at
the end is akin to the linking or the
usurpation fade not the end of fire more
reason to believe that the fire
continues to burn in this ending as well
as the linking Easter patient ones
though it does appear that the fire has
faded some amount compared to the
usurpation ending since before the fade
to black the world is noticeably darker
than it was in other non end of fire
endings I'd say that the flame
experienced some decline while the fire
keeper held it but the player stopped it
from completely fading peculiar the fire
keeper and taking the flame this would
mean that the fire would be weaker in
this ending as compared to the
usurpation ending
additionally towards the end of the
sequence the camera starts to point up
to the Sun the player almost offering
the flame to the Sun the red seeping
down from the sky lines up perfectly
with flame in the player's hands I think
this is kind of a stylistic way to go
about this ending showing that the
player with the power of the flame is
really only in servitude to the natural
forces of the world and not any other
person or God or being this juxtaposes
with the usurpation ending the player
has a sense of duty and responsibility
to serve launder even if as a lord so
quick recap the linking of the fire is
kind of prolonging the inevitable you're
not making too big of a change the end
of fire is taking the Dark Souls world
into a place that has never gone before
and I think it is a good spot for a
canonical ending if that is the
canonical ending entering into a Dark
Age that hasn't been done before in Dark
Souls or you haven't seen the results of
it done in Dark Souls before usurpation
the fire is still a little bit misty and
you are serving cop who is responsible
for a lot of
tragedies so I don't think I really like
that ending and then the secret end
afire ending however in that you really
means the fire keeper and I really like
the fire keeper so I don't think it's to
greater than ending those last points
were really all opinion so I'm not
backing that up with anything I'm just
telling you guys how I feel that does it
for my analysis of the endings in Dark
Souls 3 hope you guys have enjoyed this
video if you want more Dark Souls 3
lower my channel has a lot of its to go
check that out I appreciate you watching
this far and yet I will be returning to
lords of cinder in my next video so
people that are waiting on that get hike
thank you for watching
peace out